feuer auf der als es dieses experiment
auf der internationalen raumstation ist
wirklich sehr risikoreich feuer in einem
kamerasystem entzünden und dabei soll
herausgefunden werden wie sich in der
schwerelosigkeit ausbreitet und wie es
zu bekämpfen ist schon einmal hat die
besatzung der iss feuer gelegt dabei
sind raumschiffe komplett in brand
gesteckt worden und die ergebnisse waren
frappierend mit diesen resultaten kann
jetzt weiter geforscht werden klicks und
science fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und activity
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen das neue
experiment heißt komm feind combustion
und hierbei werden die astronauten
astronauten auf der internationalen
raumstation ein feuer entzünden
der plan sieht vor einen brennstoff
gezielt in einem system zu entzünden
dass durch trennwände in verschiedene
kammern aufgeteilt ist sechs monate lang
werden die astronauten astronauten hier
mit dem feuer herum experimentieren und
dabei unter anderem seine
strömungsgeschwindigkeit und richtung
verändern was sich wie lustige
spielereien anhört hat aber einen
ernsten hintergrund werden die
verantwortlichen forschungsteams wollen
herausfinden wie sich ein feuer in einer
solchen umgebung verbreitet das
besondere hier ist ja die mikro gravität
also die sehr verringerte schwerkraft
die das verhalten der flammen
beeinflusst so lässt sich ein feuer viel
schlechter einschätzen und genau das ist
der grund für das neue experiment con
feind combustion auf der iss die
fachleute wollen ein für alle mal
verstehen was im fall der fälle nämlich
bei einem brand auf der iss oder einem
anderen raumschiff zu tun ist auf der
erde sind flammen ganz gut kalkulierbare
die schwerkraft drückt kalte dichte luft
nach unten und füttert die flammen mit
sauerstoff in der fachsprache ist von
einem konvektion prozess die rede
das team auf der ice es jedenfalls ist
bereit für das große feuer experiment
dazu paul verkauf von der university
space research association die
astronauten freuen sich oft sehr auf
solche tests demnach sei es zitat
irgendwie faszinierend zu sehen wie
diese sachen ohne jede schwerkraft
brennen doch das feuer experiment ist
nur eines von vielen das basics mit
seiner dragon -kapsel derzeit zu als es
bringt mit dabei
sind auch einige nagetiere die etwa
einen monat lang im all bleiben sollen
vor ort bekommen sie einen wirkstoff
verabreicht ja das protein mossad ihn
blockiert denn dieses hemd das
muskelwachstum durch die gabe des
wirkstoffs könnte also möglicherweise
der knochen und muskelschwund im all bei
den tieren verhindert werden damit
nehmen die fachleute die knochen und
muskeln schwächung ins visier
die astronauten astronauten auf
raummissionen erleiden eine fatale folge
der verringerten schwerkraft ohne
gegenmassnahmen führt diese nämlich zum
muskelabbau und die fitness der
astronauten und astronautinnen geht
verloren deswegen müssen die alle
besucherinnen und besuchern nach ihrer
reise ins all erst einmal wieder lernen
auf der erde zu laufen
kein wunder denn obwohl jeden tag
krafttraining auf dem programm steht
geht die rückenmuskulatur im all um etwa
20 prozent zurück und das schon nach ein
paar monaten der sogenannte soleos
muskel in der wade schrumpft bei einem
dreiwöchigen aufenthalt immer sogar
schon um ein drittel
dadurch gehen muskelfasern verloren die
für ausdauernde bewegung nötig sind ein
spannendes und vor allem wichtiges
forschungsfeld also manche der mäuse
sind sogar gentechnisch verändert diesem
eisblöcken das protein you statt ihnen
dazu die us-wissenschaftlerin emily
dzemaili durch das testen dieses
experimentelle national mittels hoffen
wir eine neuartige therapeutische
methode zur bekämpfung von muskel und
knochenschwund nicht nur bei astronauten
im weltraum sondern auch bei vielen
menschen auf der erde testen zu können
außerdem soll auch der anbau von gerste
unter micro gravität erforscht werden
dieser test wurde von einer us
amerikanischen brauerei in auftrag
gegeben und von der nasa kommt eine
dockingstation hiermit soll ein roboter
getestet werden der nach undichten
stellen bei raumschiffen sucht das feuer
experiment ist übrigens nicht das erste
dieser art schon 2008 wurde auf der ice
es mit einem nasa experiment gearbeitet
dass auch kleinere brände beinhaltete
später folgte dann die saffir test reise
bei der 2016 bis 2017 um bemannte sojus
raumschiffe angezündet wurden das
geschah allerdings erst nach der
versorgungsmission der raumschiffe die
ansonsten sowieso in der erdatmosphäre
verglüht werden schon damals wurden
super spannende erkenntnisse gewonnen
ist
ab stetige flammen die sich deutlich
langsamer ausbreiten als auf der erde
manche materialien ließen sich in der
mikro gravität nicht einmal entflammen
selbst wenn sauerstoff zugeführt wurde
darunter zum beispiel silizium feuer aus
dem untergrund anklicken anschauen und
hyperraum tv abonnieren mega cola von
gitta kanal neu bei sn 1054 unserem
kleinen wissenschafts netzwerk also
unbedingt anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran